C'est un grand honneur d'être ici avec vous.
La bonne nouvelle est que
je suis parfaitement conscient de ma responsabilité de vous sortir d'ici
car je suis le seul obstacle entre vous et le bar.
(rires)
L'autre bonne nouvelle est que je n'ai pas préparé de discours,
mais j'ai une boîte de diapositives
J'ai quelques photos qui représentent ma vie et ce que je fais dans la vie.
J'ai appris par expérience
que les gens se souviennent des images longtemps après qu'ils aient oublié les mots.
J'espère donc que vous vous souviendrez de quelques unes des images
que je vais partager avec vous pendant quelques minutes.
L'histoire a réellement commencée
lorsque j'étais lycéen à Pittsburgh, en Pennsylvanie,
dans une banlieue difficile que tout le monde avait laissée pour morte.
Et un mercredi après midi,
alors que j´empruntais le couloir de mon lycée,
en pensant à mes occupations, il y avait un artiste donnant un cours,
qui avait fait un grand récipient en poterie.
Je me suis retrouvé à regarder à l'intérieur de la classe d'art.
Si vous n'avez jamais vu faire de la poterie, c'est magique,
et je n'avais jamais rien vu de tel dans ma vie auparavant.
Alors je suis rentré dans la classe d'art et j'ai dit "C'est quoi ça ?"
Il a dit "De la poterie - et toi, qui es-tu ? "
Et j'ai dit, "Je suis Bill Strickland. Je veux que vous m'appreniez à faire ça"
Et il a dit, "Eh bien, dis à ton professeur principal de signer un papier
qui dit que tu peux venir ici, et je te l'apprendrai."
Et pendant mes deux dernières années de lycée,
j'ai séché tous mes cours.
(rires)
Mais j'ai eu la présence d'esprit
de donner aux profs des cours que je séchais les poteries que j'avais faites ...
(rires)
et ils m'ont donné de bonnes notes.
C'est comme ça que j'ai terminé le lycée.
Et Mr Ross a dit,
"Tu es trop intelligent pour mourir, et je ne veux pas ça sur ma conscience,
alors je quitte cette école et je t'emmène avec moi."
Et il m'a conduit à l'université de Pittsburgh
ou j'ai rempli un formulaire d'entrée et ai été pris à l'essai.
Voilà, je suis maintenant au conseil d'administration de l'université
et, à ma cérémonie d'intronisation, j'ai dit :
"Je suis celui qui est venu de la banlieue
et a été pris ici à l'essai.
N'abandonnez pas les enfants pauvres parce qu'on ne sait jamais
ce qui va leur arriver dans la vie."
Ce que je vais vous montrer pendant quelques minutes
est un complexe que j'ai construit dans la banlieue la plus difficile de Pittsburgh
avec le taux de criminalité le plus haut.
Cela s'appelle le Bidwell training center, c'est une école professionnelle
pour les ex métalliurgistes, les parents célibataires et les mères bénéficiant d'aide sociale
Vous vous souvenez que l'on fabriquait de l'acier à Pittsburgh ?
Eh bien, on n'en fabrique plus
et les personnes qui fabriquaient l'acier
vivent des temps très difficiles du coup.
Et je les reconstruis et leur donne une nouvelle vie.
La guilde des artisans de Manchester est baptisée d'après ma banlieue.
J'ai été adopté
par l'évêque du diocèse épiscopal pendant les émeutes.
Et il a fait don d'une maison, et dans cette maison,
j'ai commencé la guilde des artisans de Manchester.
Et j'ai appris très rapidement que là ou il y a des épiscopaliens,
il y a de l'argent pas loin.
(rires)
Et l'évêque m'a adopté comme son fils.
L'année dernière, je me suis exprimé à son service funèbre
et lui ai dit adieu.
Je suis allé embaucher un étudiant de l'architecte Frank Lloyd Wright
et lui ai demandé de me construire un centre de classe mondiale
dans la pire banlieue de Pittsburgh.
Et mon bâtiment a servi de modèle réduit pour l'aéroport de Pittsburgh.
Si vous venez à Pittsburgh, et vous êtes tous invités,
vous atterrirez dans la version agrandie de mon bâtiment.
Voici le bâtiment.
Construit dans une banlieue difficile où les gens avaient été laissés pour morts.
D'après moi, si vous voulez vous impliquer
dans la vie de gens qui ont été abandonnés,
vous devez ressembler à la solution et pas au problème.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, il y a une fontaine dans la cour
et s'il y a une fontaine dans la cour c'est parce que j'en voulais une.
Et j'avais le carnet de chèques alors j'en ai acheté une et l'ai mise là.
(rires)
Et maintenant que je m'exprime à des conférences comme TED,
je suis devenu membre du conseil du Carnegie Museum,
et à une réception dans leur cour, j'ai remarqué qu'ils avaient une fontaine
parce qu'ils pensent que les gens qui vont au musée méritent une fontaine.
Eh bien je pense que les mères qui bénéficient de l'aide sociale, les enfants à risque
et les ex-métallurgistes méritent une fontaine dans leur vie.
Alors la première chose que vous voyez dans mon centre au printemps
est l'eau qui vous accueille, l'eau est la vie, l'eau des capacités humaines.
Cela définit une attitude et une idée
de la façon dont vous considérez les gens, avant même que vous leur fassiez un discours.
A partir de cette fontaine, j'ai construit ce bâtiment.
Comme vous voyez, il y a de l'art de renommée mondiale, d'après mes goûts
parce que j'ai réuni l'argent.
(rires)
J'ai dit à mon fils, "Quand tu réuniras l'argent,
on décorera les murs à ton goût."
Mais nous avons des tapisseries, des poteries et des calligraphies,
et partout ou vous posez vos yeux,
quelque chose de magnifique vous rend votre regard.
C'est délibéré.
C'est intentionnel.
D'après moi, c'est ce genre de monde
qui peut racheter les âmes des gens pauvres.
Nous avons aussi créé une salle de conseil.
J'ai engagé un ébéniste japonais de Kyoto au Japon,
et lui ai commandé 60 meubles pour notre bâtiment.
Depuis, nous l'avons aidé à lancer son entreprise.
Il gagne un tas d'argent en faisant des meubles sur mesure pour les riches.
Et j'ai eu 60 de ses pièces pour mon école
parce que j'avais l'impression que les assistés sociaux, les ex-métallurgistes
et les parents célibataires méritaient de venir dans une école
où ils étaient accueillis chaque jour par des meubles sculptés à la main
parce que cela définit un ton et une attitude à propos de la façon dont vous considérez les gens
bien avant que vous leur fassiez un discours.
Nous avons même des fleurs dans le hall et elles ne sont pas en plastique,
elles sont vraies, et elles sont dans mon bâtiment chaque jour.
Et maintenant que j'ai fait beaucoup de conférences
un tas de proviseurs de lycée sont venus me voir
et m'ont dit, " Mr Strickland,
quelle extraordinaire histoire et quelle magnifique école.
Nous avons été particulièrement impressionnés par les fleurs
et nous sommes curieux de savoir comment elles sont arrivées ici."
J'ai dit, "J'ai pris ma voiture et je suis allé chez l'horticulteur
je les ai achetées, les ai ramenées ici et les ai posées là."
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'un groupe de travail ou d'un cabinet d'études pour acheter des fleurs à vos enfants.
Ce que vous avez besoin de savoir est que les enfants
et les adultes méritent des fleurs dans leur vie.
Le coût est minime mais le geste est immense.
Et donc dans mon bâtiment, qui est plein de fleurs et de rayons de soleil,
nous croyons à l'espoir et aux capacités humaines.
Ca, c'est pendant la période de Noël.
Et la prochaine chose que vous allez voir est une cuisine à un million de dollars
construite par la compagnie Heinz - vous les connaissez ?
Ils se sont bien débrouillés dans le milieu du ketchup.
Il se trouve que je connais plutôt bien cette entreprise
car John Heinz, notre sénateur -
qui a été tué dans un tragique accident d'avion -
avait entendu parler de mon envie de construire un nouveau bâtiment
car j'avais un carton que j'avais mis dans un sac poubelle
et je marchais à travers Pittsburgh, en essayant de réunir de l'argent pour ce site.
Et il m'a appelé dans son bureau
ce qui est l'équivalent d'une visite au magicien d'Oz
(rires)
John Heinz avait 600 million de dollars, et à l'époque j'avais environ 60 cents.
Et il a dit, "Mais on a entendu parler de vous.
Nous sommes au courant de votre travail avec les enfants et les ex-métallurgistes,
et nous aimerions soutenir votre désir de construire un nouveau bâtiment.
Et vous pourriez nous rendre un grand service
Si vous ajoutiez un programme culinaire à votre programme -
parce qu'à l'époque nous mettions en place un programme d'économie.
Il m'a dit" De cette manière, la compagnie Heinz pourrait remplir
ses objectifs d'aide sociale."
J'ai dit, " Sénateur, je suis réticent à me lancer dans un domaine
auquel je ne connais pas grand chose mais je vous promets
que si vous soutenez mon école, je la construirai
et je reviendrai dans quelques années
pour considérer le programme que vous désirez."
Le sénateur Heinz s'est assis très calmement et a dit,
"Quelle serait votre réaction si je vous disais
que je vous donne un million de dollars ?"
J'ai dit, " Sénateur, dans ce cas nous allons nous lancer dans l'économie du commerce alimentaire."
(rires)
Et John Heinz m'a effectivement donné un million de dollars.
Et, plus important,
Il m'a prêté le directeur de la recherche pour la compagnie Heinz.
Et nous avons en quelque sorte emprunté le programme de l'institut culinaire d'Amérique,
qui est, dans leur esprit, le Harvard des écoles de cuisine.
Et nous avons créé un programme de chefs gastronomiques pour les assistés sociaux
dans cette cuisine à un million de dollars au milieu du centre ville.
Sans jamais le regretter.
Je voudrais maintenant vous montrer quelques plats
que ces mères célibataires préparent dans cette cuisine à un million de dollars.
Ceci est notre menu à la cafétéria.
C'est le jour de la pâtes feuilletée. Pourquoi ?
Parce que les étudiants avaient préparé de la pâte feuilletée
et c'est ce que l'école mangeait chaque jour.
Mais mon concept était de détruire les préjugés sur la nourriture.
Car la bonne nourriture n'est pas pour les riches,
la bonne nourriture est pour tout le monde sur cette planète
et il n'y a aucune excuse pour que tout le monde n'en profite pas.
Alors, dans mon école, nous subventionnons un programme de déjeuner gastronomique
pour les mères bénéficiant de l'aide sociale au milieu du centre ville
car nous avons découvert que c'est bon pour leurs estomacs,
mais que c'est encore meilleur pour leurs têtes.
Car je voulais leur faire savoir chaque jour de leur vie
qu'elles ont de la valeur dans cet endroit que j'appelle mon centre.
Nos étudiants s'asseyent ensemble, enfants noirs et enfants blancs,
et nous avons découvert que l'on peut résoudre le problème des races
en créant un environnement de rang mondial
parce que les gens ont tendance à faire preuve d'un comportement de rang mondial
lorsqu'on les traite de cette manière.
Ce sont des exemples de plats que ces mères font
après six mois dans le programme d'apprentissage.
Pas de manières, pas de préjugés de classe, pas de snobisme, pas d'histoire.
Ce que nous avons découvert est que le seul problème avec les gens pauvres
est qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent, mais il se trouve que ça se soigne.
C'est uniquement ce que vous pensez des gens
qui détermine leur comportement.
Ceci a été préparé par une étudiante après sept mois dans notre programme,
fait par une très brillante jeune femme
formée par notre chef pâtissier
J'ai mangé sept de ces paniers et ils sont très bons.
(rires)
Ils n'ont pas de calories.
Voici notre salle à manger.
Elle ressemble à n'importe quelle cafétéria de lycée
dans une ville américaine moyenne.
Mais c'est, d'après moi, la manière dont les étudiants doivent être traités
particulièrement s'ils ont été mis de côté.
Nous formons des laborantins pour l'industrie pharmaceutique.
Nous formons des techniciens médicaux pour l'industrie médicale.
Et nous formons des techniciens en chimie pour des entreprises
comme Bayer et Calgon Carbon et Fisher Scientific et Exxon.
Et je vous garantis que si vous venez dans mon centre à Pittsburgh -
et vous êtes tous invités -
vous verrez des mères bénéficiant de l'assistance sociale faisant de la chimie analytique
avec des calculatrices logarithmiques,
10 mois après s'être inscrites au programme.
Il n'y a aucune raison pour laquelle les gens pauvres
ne pourraient apprendre des technologies de rang mondial.
Ce que nous avons découvert est que vous devez leur donner des fleurs,
des rayons de soleil, de la nourriture, des attentes et la musique de Herbie
et vous pourrez soigner un cancer spirituel à chaque fois.
Nous formons des agents de voyage pour l'industrie du tourisme.
Nous apprenons même aux gens à lire.
Le gamin avec la bande rouge était dans le programme il y a 2 ans,
Il est maintenant instructeur.
Et je vois des enfants avec des diplômes de lycée qu'ils ne savent pas lire.
Et vous devez vous poser la question :
comment est-il possible qu'au 21ème siècle
nous laissions partir les enfants des écoles
alors qu'ils ne peuvent pas lire le diplôme qu'ils tiennent dans leurs mains ?
La raison est que le système est remboursé
pour les enfants qui sont recrachés à l'autre bout, pas pour ceux qui savent lire.
Je peux prendre ces enfants et en 20 semaines,
en testant leurs capacités, je peux leur faire atteindre le niveau du lycée.
Pas de problème.
Voici notre bibliothèque avec d'autres meubles faits main.
Et voici le programme d'arts que j'ai commencé en 1968.
Souvenez vous que je suis le gamin noir des 60's dont la poterie a sauvé la vie.
Eh bien, quand j'ai décidé de reproduire mon expérience
avec d'autres enfants de la banlieue,
la théorie étant que si vous donnez aux gamins des fleurs, de la nourriture
des rayons de soleil et de l'enthousiasme,
vous pouvez les ramener à la vie.
J'ai 400 enfants du système d'éducation publique de Pittsburgh
qui viennent vers moi chaque jour de la semaine pour l'éducation artistique.
Et ce sont des enfants qui se plantent dans le système public.
Et l'année dernière, j'ai envoyé 88 % de ces enfants à la fac
et j'ai atteint en moyenne 80 % sur 15 ans.
Nous avons fait une découverte fascinante
Il n'y a pas de problème avec ces enfants
que l'affection, les rayons de soleil, la nourriture, l'enthousiasme
et la musique d'Herbie ne puisse soigner.
Pour cela, j'ai gagné une belle grosse plaque, homme de l'année de l'éducation.
J'ai battu tous les diplômés
parce que je me suis dit que si vous traitez les enfants comme des êtres humains
cela augmente les chances qu'ils se comportent comme tels.
Et pourquoi nous ne pourrions pas instaurer cette règle
dans chaque école, chaque ville et chaque village,
cela reste un mystère pour moi.
Laissez moi vous montrer ce que ces gens peuvent faire.
Nous avons de la céramique, de la photographie et du dessin par ordinateur
et tous ces gamins sans aptitude artistique, sans talent
sans imagination, et nous faisons venir les plus grands artistes du monde -
Gordon Parks est venu, Chester Higgins est venu -
et ce que nous avons appris,
c'est que ces enfants vont devenir comme les gens qui leur ont enseigné.
En fait, j'ai fait venir un artiste en mosaique du Vatican,
Une africaine-américaine
qui a étudié les anciennes techniques de mosaique du Vatican
et, laissez moi vous montrer ce qu'ils en ont fait.
Ce sont des enfants que le monde entier avait abandonnés
qui se plantaient en école publique,
et c'est ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
avec de l'affection, des rayons de soleil, de la nourriture, de la bonne musique et de la confiance.
Nous enseignons la photographie.
Voici des exemples du travail de certains gamins.
Ce garçon a gagné une bourse scolaire de 4 ans
grâce à cette photographie.
Voici notre galerie.
Nous avons une galerie de niveau mondial
parce que nous pensons que les enfants pauvres ont besoin d'une galerie de niveau mondial.
Alors j'ai conçu ceci.
Nous havons du saumon fumé pour les vernissages
Nous havons une invitation imprimée officielle
Et j'ai même trouvé un moyen de faire venir les parents
Je n'arrivais pas à ramener un seul parent il y a 15 ans.
Alors j'ai engagé un gars qui était à fond dans Jesus.
Il sortait les gens des bars
et sauvait des vies pour le Seigneur.
Et j'ai dit, "Bill, mon gars, je veux t'engager.
Il faut y aller moins fort avec Jesus
mais tu gardes le même enthousiasme.
(rires)
Je n'arrive pas à faire venir les parents à l'école."
Il m'a dit, "Je les ferai venir à l'école."
Alors il a sauté dans son camion, est allé chez Miss Jones et a dit,
"Miss Jones, je sais que vous vouliez venir au vernissage de vote gamin,
mais que vous n'aviez probablement pas de moyen de transport.
Alors je suis venu vous chercher."
Et il a eu 10 parents puis 20 parents.
A la dernière exposition que nous avons fait, 200 parents sont venus
sans que nous allions en chercher un seul.
Parce que maintenant ce n'est plus socialement acceptable de ne pas venir
soutenir vos enfants à la guilde des artisans de Manchester
parce que les gens pensent que vous êtes de mauvais parents.
Et il n'y a aucune différence statistique
entre les parents blancs et les parents noirs.
Les mères iront là où leurs enfants sont félicités,
à chaque fois, dans chaque village, dans chaque ville.
Je voulais que vous voyiez cette galerie parce qu'il n'y a pas mieux.
Au moment ou je laisse partir ces gamins du lycée,
ils ont 4 spectacles sur leurs CV
avant qu'ils s'inscrivent au collège parce que tout se passe là haut.
Vous devez changer la manière dont les gens se voient
avant qu'ils puissent changer leur comportement.
Et ça a plutôt bien marché jusqu'à ce jour.
J'ai même rajouté une nouvelle pièce au bâtiment que j'aimerais vous montrer.
C'est tout neuf.
On a fait cette diapo juste à temps pour TED.
J'ai montré ce diaporama dans un endroit appelé la Silicon Valley
et j'ai bien fait.
Une femme du public est venue,
elle a dit, "C'était une belle histoire
et j'ai été très impressionnée par votre présentation.
Ma seule critique est que vos ordinateurs sont un peu vieux."
Et j'ai dit, "Qu'est ce que vous faites dans la vie ?"
Elle a dit, "Eh bien, je travaille pour une entreprise qui s'appelle Hewlett Packard."
Et j'ai dit, "Vous êtes dans les ordinateurs, c'est bien ça ?"
Elle a dit, "Oui, monsieur."
Et j'ai dit, "Bon, il y a une solution évidente à ce problème."
Je suis heureux de vous annoncer que HP
et une entreprise d'ameublement appelée Steelcase
nous ont choisis comme lieu de démonstration pour toute leur technologie
et tout leurs meubles pour les Etats Unis d'Amérique.
Et voici la pièce.
Voilà ce qui inaugure notre collaboration.
Nous l'avons finie juste à temps pour vous montrer.
Alors c'est un peu l'inauguration de notre centre d'imagerie digitale.
(applaudissements)
(music)
J'ai encore quelques diapositives,
et c'est là que l'histoire commence à devenir intéressante.
Alors j'aimerais juste que vous écoutiez quelques minutes de plus
et vous comprendrez pourquoi il est ici et pourquoi je suis là.
En 1986, j'ai eu la présence d'esprit d'ajouter une salle de concert
au nord du bâtiment pendant la construction.
Et un homme nommé Dizzy Gillespie est venu jouer là
parce qu'il connaissait cet homme là-bas, Marty Ashby.
Et j'étais sur la scène avec Dizzy Gillespie pendant les balances
un mercredi après-midi, et j'ai dit,
"Dizzy, pourquoi viens-tu dans un centre géré par des blacks
qui n'a aucune réputation dans le domaine musical
au milieu d'un parc industriel avec un fort taux de criminalité ?"
Il a dit, "Parce que j'ai entendu que tu avais construit ce centre
et je n'y croyais pas, et je voulais voir par moi-même.
Et maintenant que j'ai vu, je voudrais te faire un cadeau."
J'ai dit, "C'est toi le cadeau."
Il a dit, "Non, monsieur. C'est toi le cadeau.
Et je vais t'autoriser à enregistrer le concert,
et je vais te donner la musique.
Et si tu choisis de la vendre, tu dois signer un accord
qui dit que l'argent reviendra et sera investi dans l'école."
Et j'ai enregistré Dizzy, et il est mort un an plus tard,
mais pas avant d'avoir dit à un de ses amis appelé McCoy Tyner ce que l'on faisait.
Et il est venu et a dit,
"Dizzy parle de toi à travers tout le pays, mon gars,
et je veux t'aider."
Et puis un gars appelé Wynton Marsalis est venu.
Puis un bassiste appelé Ray Brown,
et un gars appelé Stanley Turrentine,
et un pianiste appelé Herbie Hancock,
et un groupe appelé the Count Basie Orchestra,
et un gars appelé Tito Puente,
et un gars appelé Gary Burton, et Shirley Horn, et Betty Carter,
et Dakota Staton et Nancy Wilson.
Tous sont venus dans ce centre au milieu d'un parc industriel,
à guichets fermés, au milieu du centre ville.
Et je suis heureux de vous dire que, avec leur permission,
J'ai maintenant accumulé 600 enregistrements
des plus grands artistes du monde,
y compris Joe Williams, qui est mort,
mais pas avant que son dernier enregistrement soit fait dans mon école.
Et joe Williams est venu vers moi et il a mis sa main sur mon épaule
et il a dit, "Dieu t'as choisi, mon gars, pour faire ce boulot
et je veux que ma musique soit avec toi."
Et ça a bien marché.
Quand le band de Basie est venu, le groupe était tellement excité par l'école
qu'ils ont voté pour me donner les droits de la musique.
Et je l'ai enregistrée et nous avons gagné quelque chose que l'on appelle un Grammy.
Et, comme un idiot, je ne suis pas allé à la cérémonie
parce que je ne pensais pas qu'on allait gagner.
Eh bien, on a gagné.
Et notre nom était littéralement en lumières au-dessus de Madison Square Garden.
Puis l'orchestre de Jazz de L'O.N.U. est venu et on les a enregistrés
et on a été nominés pour un second Grammy d'affilée.
Alors on est devenu un de ces jeunes studio d'enregistrements de jazz à la mode
aux U.S.A.
(rires)
au milieu du centre ville avec un fort taux de criminalité.
Voici l'endroit rempli de républicains.
(rires)
(applaudissements)
Si vous aviez lâché une bombe dans cette pièce,
vous auriez détruit tout l'argent de Pennsylvanie
parce qu'ils étaient tous assis là
même ma mère et mon père, qui ont vécu assez longtemps
pour voir leur fils construire ce bâtiment.
Et voilà Dizzy, comme je vous l'ai dit, il était là.
Et il était là, Tito Puente,
Et Pat Metheny et Jim Hall étaient là
et ils ont enregistré avec nous.
Et voici notre premier studio d'enregistrement, qui était un placard à balais.
On a mis les serpillères dans le couloir et réorganisé la chose
et c'est là qu'on a enregistré notre premier Grammy.
et voilà notre nouvelle installation, avec toute la technologie vidéo.
Et ça, c'est une pièce construite pour une femme appelée Nancy Wilson,
qui a enregistré cet album dans notre école à noël dernier.
Et pour ceux d'entre vous qui avez regardé Oprah Winfrey
le jour de Noël, il était là et Nancy était là,
chantant des extraits de cet album,
dont elle a donné les droits à notre école.
Et je peux maintenant vous dire avec une absolue certitude,
que la présence d'Oprah Winfrey fait vendre 10,000 CD.
(rires)
Nous sommes actuellement 4ème au classement Billboard
juste derrière Tony Bennett.
Et je pense que ça va bien se passer.
Cela a été brûlé pendant les émeutes, c'est juste à côté de mon bâtiment
Alors je me suis fait faire une autre boîte en carton
et je suis retourné marcher dans la rue.
Et voici le bâtiment, et ça c'est la maquette,
et sur la droite, c'est la serre high-tech
et au milieu, le bâtiment de technologies médicales.
Et je suis très heureux de vous annoncer que le bâtiment est terminé
c'est aussi plein d'espaces à louer à 20 dollars le pied
multipliez ça par 3 au milieu du centre ville.
Et voilà la fontaine.
(rires)
Chaque bâtiment a un fontaine.
Et le centre médical de l'université de Pittsburgh sont locataires
et ils ont pris la moitié du bâtiment.
Et nous formons maintenant des techniciens médicaux à travers tout leur système.
Et la banque Mellon est locataire.
Et je les adore parce qu'ils paient leur loyer à l'heure.
(rires)
Grâce à cette association,
je suis maintenant un directeur de la Mellon Financial Corporation
qui a acheté Dreyfus.
Et ceci est en construction alors même que nous parlons.
multipliez cette image par 4 et vous verrez la serre
qui s'ouvrira en octobre de cette année
parce que l'on va faire pousser ces fleurs
au milieu du centre ville.
Et nous aurons des lycéens qui feront pousser
des orchidées phalaenopsis au milieu du centre ville
et nous avons un marché avec un des géants de la grande distribution
pour vendre nos orchidées dans 240 boutiques dans six états.
Et nos partenaires sont Zuma Canyon Orchids de Malibu, en Californie,
qui sont des hispano-américains.
Donc les hispaniques et la population noire ont formé un partenariat
pour faire pousser des orchidées de haute technologie au milieu du centre ville.
J'ai dit à mon sénateur
que s'il pouvait trouver des fonds pour cela,
il y avait une grande probabilité
que nous finissions dans la colonne de gauche du Wall Street Journal.
Chose qu'il a immédiatement acceptée.
Nous avons les subventions et nous ouvrons en automne.
Et vous devriez venir voir, ça va être encore une sacrée histoire.
Et c'est ce que je veux faire quand je serai grand.
(rires)
Le bâtiment marron est celui que vous avez vu,
et je vais vous dire ou j'ai fait ma plus grosse erreur.
J'avais une occasion d'acheter tout ce parc industriel
qui est à moins de 1000 pieds du bord de rivière
pour 4 million de dollars et je ne l'ai pas fait.
Et j'ai construit le premier bâtiment, et devinez ce qui est arrivé ?
J'ai relevé la valeur immobilière du terrain au-dessus des attentes de tout le monde
et les propriétaires du parc me l´ont proposé pour 8 millions de dollars l´an dernier.
Et m'ont dit, " Mr Strickland,
vous devriez recevoir le prix du Leader Local de l'année
parce que vous avez relevé la valeur de notre propriété
au-delà de nos rêves les plus fous.
Merci beaucoup pour cela."
La morale de tout cela est que vous devriez toujours être préparés à agir en accord avec vos rêves,
juste au cas où ils se réaliseraient.
Et finalement, il y a cette photo.
C'est à un endroit appelé San Francisco.
Et la raison pour laquelle la photo est là est que
j'ai fait cette présentation à un grand sommet économique il y a quelques années
et une personne du public est venue vers moi.
Il m'a dit, "Mon gars, c'est une histoire magnifique.
J'en veux un comme ça."
J'ai dit: "Eh bien, je suis très flatté. Vous faites quoi dans la vie ?"
Il a dit: "Je gère la ville de San Francisco.
Mon nom est Willie Brown."
Alors j'ai accepté les compliments et les flatteries
et ça m'est sorti de la tête.
Et ce week end là, je suis rentré à la maison
et Herbie Hancock jouait à notre centre ce soir-là -
c´était la première fois que je l'ai rencontré.
Mais il est rentré et il a dit, "Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?"
Et j'ai dit, Herbie, c'est ma vision d'un centre de formation
pour les gens pauvres."
Et il a dit : "Dieu m'en est témoin,
j'avais un centre comme ça dans ma tête depuis 25 and et tu l'as construit.
Et maintenant, j'ai vraiment envie d'en faire un."
J'ai dit, "Ah bon, et tu ferais ça où ?"
Il m'a dit, "San Francisco."
J'ai dit, "Tu connaitrais pas Willie Brown par hasard ?"
(rires)
En fait, il connaissait Willie Brown,
et Willie Brown, Herbie et moi avons diné ensemble il y a 4 ans,
et on a commencé à dessiner ce centre sur la nappe.
Et Willie Brown a dit, "Aussi vrai que je suis le maire de San Francisco,
je vais construire ce truc
comme un héritage aux pauvres gens de cette ville."
Et il m'a donné 5 acres de terre sur la baie de San Fancisco
et on a trouvé un architecte et un entrepreneur
et on a fait entrer Herbie au conseil,
et nos amis d'HP, nos amis de Steelcase,
et nos amis de Cisco, et nos amis de Wells Fargo
et de Genentech.
Et au cours du chemin, j'ai rencontré un tout petit gars
à un diaporama dans Silicon Valley.
Il est venu vers moi après.
Il a dit, "Mon gars, c'est une histoire magnifique,
J'aimerais t'aider."
Et j'ai dit, "Eh bien, merci beaucoup.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais dans la vie ?"
Il a dit, "Eh bien, j'ai monté une entreprise qui s'appelle eBay."
J'ai dit, "Ah, très bien.
Merci beaucoup, laisse moi ta carte et on discutera un de ces jours."
Je ne connaissais pas plus eBay que le pichet d'eau sur le piano.
Mais j'ai eu la présence d'esprit de rentrer
et de parler à un des gamins techniciens de mon centre.
J'ai dit, "Hey, c'est quoi eBay ?"
Il a dit, " Ben, c'est un réseau de commerce électronique."
J'ai dit, "J'ai rencontré le gars qui a monté ce truc
et il m'a laissé sa carte."
Alors je l'ai appelé et j'ai dit, "Mr Skoll,
je me suis renseigné plus profondément sur qui vous êtes,
(rires)
et j'aimerais devenir votre ami."
Et Jeff et moi sommes devenus amis,
et il a réuni un groupe de personnes
et nous allons construire ce centre
Alors je suis allé dans une banlieue appelée Bayview-Hunters Point
et j'ai dit, " Le maire m'a envoyé pour travailler avec vous
et je veux construire un centre avec vous,
mais je ne le construirai pas si vous n'en voulez pas.
Et tout ce que j'avais était une boîte de diapos."
Alors je me suis retrouvé devant 200 personnes, très mécontentes et décues
un soir d'été, et l'air conditionné ne marchait pas
et il faisait près de 40 degrés dehors,
et j'ai commencé à montrer ces images.
Et après environ 10 photos ils se sont calmés,
j'ai raconté mon histoire et j'ai dit, " Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?"
Et au fond de la salle, une femme s'est levée et a dit,
"Depuis 35 ans que je vis dans cet endroit abandonné de tous,
vous êtes la seule personne qui soit venue et nous ait traité avec dignité.
Je suis avec toi, mon gars."
Et elle a rallié tout le public à elle.
Et j'ai promis à ces gens que j'allais construire ce truc.
Et on va le faire.
Et je pense qu'on peut commencer à creuser cette année,
comme la première copie du centre de Pittsburgh.
Mais j'ai rencontré un gars qui s'appelle Quincy Jones en chemin
et je lui ai montré mon diaporama.
Et Qunicy a dit, " J'ai envie de t'aider mon gars.
On va en faire un à Los Angeles."
Alors il a réuni un groupe de gens
Et je suis tombé amoureux de lui,
comme je l'ai fait avec Herbie et sa musique.
Et Quincy a dit," D'où t'es venue l'idée pour ces centres ?"
Et j'ai dit, "Ca vient de ta musique, mon gars,
parce que Mr Ross avait l'habitude d'amener tes albums,
quand j'avais 16 ans dans la classe de poterie,
quand le monde n'était que ténèbres,
et ta musique m'a emmené vers le soleil."
Et je me suis dit, " Si je peux suivre cette musique,
je sortirai dans la lumière et tout ira bien.
Et si c'est pas vrai, comment suis-je arrivé là ?
Je veux que vous sachiez tous
que je pense que le monde est un endroit où ça vaut la peine de vivre.
Je crois en vous.
Je crois en vos espoirs et vos rêves.
Je crois en votre intelligence.
Et je crois en votre enthousiasme.
Et je suis fatigué de vivre comme ça,
à aller de ville en ville et voir des gens à tous les coins de rue
avec des trous à la palce des yeux, leurs esprits détruits.
On ne tiendra pas en tant que pays à moins qu'on n'inverse la vapeur.
En Pennsylvanie, ça coûte 60,000 dollars pour garder les gens en prison,
la plupart d'entre eux me ressemble.
C'est 40,000 dollars pour construire l'école médicale de l'Université de Pittsburgh
Ca coûte 20.000 dollars de moins de construire une école médicale que de garder des gens en prison.
Faites le calcul, ça marchera jamais.
Je mise sur vous
et je mise sur des gens comme Herbie et Quincy et Hackett et Richard
et des gens très bien qui croient encore en quelque chose.
Et je veux faire ça de mon vivant, dans chaque ville et dans chaque village.
Et je ne pense pas que je sois fou.
Je crois qu'on peut aller au bout de ce truc
et je pense qu'on peux construire ces trucs dans tout le pays
pour moins d'argent que ce qu'on dépense dans les prisons.
Et je crois qu'on peut changer cette histoire
en une histoire de joie et d'espoir.
Dans mon métier, c'est beaucoup de travail,
vous nagez toujours contre le courant, comme un saumon,
jamais assez d'argent, trop de besoins.
Il y a toujours une tendance
à déprimer qui accompagne mon travail.
Au cours du temps, je me suis rendu compte, que la solution contre la dépression
est d'avoir un ami dans chaque ville, pour ne jamais être seul.
J'espère donc m'en être fait quelques uns ce soir.
Merci d'avoir écouté ce que j'avais à dire.
(applaudissements)